we now have heard from former national
security adviser john bolton
and former attorney to donald trump and
friend of the show michael cohen
both believe that donald trump probably
has won more documents at some of his
other houses
and number two
even copies of the documents that were
seized by the fbi and it really wouldn't
be surprising that both are true let's
first listen to trump's former national
security adviser john bolton
not a guy that i like politically i
think he is a depraved warmongering
individual but i've not known him to be
overtly dishonest in interviews that he
does uh when it comes to just basic
factual matters sure he'll distort about
the case for war
he's done that before
but he has appeared to be completely
straightforward at least on factual
matters of this sort take a listen to
what he had to say when he was
interviewed well given that it's donald
trump we're talking about i'm not
surprised in the slightest and i
wouldn't be surprised if there were more
highly classified documents at
bedminster or some some other residents
of his
i just think it's important that
everybody whether they're pro-trump or
anti-trump or whatever their position is
to try and take a deep breath here let
this process play out you know the the
the filing that was done last night in
the united states that included that
picture that you've shown there and a
lot of information about the documents
and about uh
trump's uh obstruction is the word they
use the refusal to turn them over to the
national archives is revealing bit by
bit the the seriousness of the case and
we we don't know all the details yet it
could be very very serious but my uh
strong urging to everybody is stay calm
let's let it play out we've got due
process in the united states the facts
will come out here but let's not jump to
conclusions that the justice department
is an arm of the democratic party uh on
the one hand or the trump ought to go to
jail tomorrow on the other yeah and of
course there's no evidence that this
justice department investigation is
operating at the direction of joe biden
or any such thing now we heard something
similar from michael cohen michael cohen
tweeted quote i have been saying
since the fbi i i've been saying this
since the fbi raid i believe trump has
copies
potentially other documents as well at
other locations including his children's
homes
weisselberg's florida home allen
weisselberg is the cfo now indicted of
trump's um business bedminster new
jersey golf course
fifth avenue apartment etc
now if this is true and it's completely
plausibly true there are probably
foreign spies already trying to
infiltrate those locations with how easy
it has been for foreign agents to get
into mar-a-lago over the last few years
it would not be shocking at all that
some of our adversaries are already
looking at whether donald trump has
other documents or copies of documents
at some of his other homes and it
you know we talked earlier about
is the doj being political
if they are deliberately waiting until
after the midterms to indict trump
the more i learn
the more it sounds like they're nowhere
near ready to charge because they may
need to have more search warrants they
may need to uh pull try to find
documents at other of trump's homes the
way things are looking and at this point
from a national security standpoint it
has to be assumed that everything's
compromised all of
any of these documents that trump took
it has to be assumed that our
adversaries may have gotten their hands
on them um it has to be assumed that
there are copies because it's trump
after all and the person who is now
trying to clean up this mess but only
making things worse is donald trump's
spokeswoman liz harrington let's talk
about her next